it's all fun and games until a few
animated rabbits give the kids
Everlasting Trauma from allegorical
genocide to Doodles that would make your
mom blush these cartoons are anything
but your typical Saturday morning Fair
it wasn't too long ago when the Tim
Burton produced computer animated film
nine hit theaters to a resoundingly
lukewarm reception this was a movie that
had a lot going for it before release
including a star-studded voice cast and
a seemingly interesting post-apocalyptic
premise it featured the talent of
performers like John C Reilly Jennifer
Connelly Christopher Plummer Crispin
Glover and Martin Landau in starring
roles as creepy little robot dolls
reanimated in a post-apocalypse nine is
centered around a doll named nine who
must fight against an evil artificial
intelligence that has destroyed all life
on Earth while the movie had interesting
Concepts and ideas it failed to present
them in a coherent way especially in a
way that kids could understand the story
focused on nine self-conscious ragdolls
called Stitch punks which contain
different aspects of their Creator's
soul that is why I am making each of you
you're all that's left of humanity nine
himself is based on their Creator's
inherent humanity and functions as the
heart of the team other Stitch punks
have traits like healing Fighting Fear
creativity and arrogance which are all
meant to work together in unison while
this may seem interesting on the surface
nine struggles to explain these complex
ideas in an engaging way when it comes
to really weird experimental animated
films it doesn't get more iconic than
Renee lalu's Fantastic Planet this 1973
piece of Science Fiction was a unique
co-production between French and
Czechoslovakian filmmakers centered
around humans in the far future living
on a planet controlled by gigantic blue
humanoids humans in this world are
treated as pets or pests and the plot
mainly focuses on the relationship
between the alien Tiva and a human child
named Terre who is taken in as a pet
Fantastic Planet is a gorgeous strange
and appropriately fantastic film that
nonetheless confuses many audiences
thanks to its deeper subtext the entire
movie is an allegorical story
representing social issues like animal
rights abuse racism and human rights in
general much of this can be lost on
viewers who don't fully understand the
connection between the mesmerizing
visuals a fantastic planet and their
connection to these deeper themes it
certainly doesn't help that the English
language dub of the film completely
altered parts of the dialogue and story
in an attempt to make it more
kid-friendly so if you give Fantastic
Planet a try make sure to watch it in
the original French release
yes somebody actually made an animated
musical comedy about the Titanic sinking
Camilo tetty's Titanic the legend goes
on is an Italian reimagining of this
actual historical event with the
addition of creative Liberties like
talking animals and musical numbers
obviously spinning off the success of
James Cameron's 1997 Blockbuster Titanic
this movie baffled the minds of anyone
who watched it because of how
unbelievably bad it was unlike its
cinematic predecessor Titanic the legend
goes on has little regard for the actual
story of the Titanic and instead adds
things you'd typically see in a standard
children's animated film the story is
focused on the budding relationship
between a third class passenger named
Angelica and an upper crust rich man
named William which Probably sounds
familiar what's really confusing is the
addition of multiple talking animals
ripped straight from an different movie
this Titanic has gone on to be
considered one of the worst animated
movies of all time by both critics and
audiences alike Christopher Campbell of
Indie wire Put It Best in his piece 100
Years of terrible Titanic exploitations
in film TV and slides by describing the
film as so terribly written and drawn
that it's offensive to the Titanic's
memory
heavy metal is one of the wildest movies
of the 1980s featuring a mix of intense
sci-fi visuals and a hardcore Rock
soundtrack that still slaps to this day
directed by Gerald potterton and
produced by comedy Legend Ivan Reitman
this movie is best known for its
gratuitous content rather than its
narrative cohesion some of the iconic
bands to have their music featured in
the film include Blue Oyster Cult Black
Sabbath Devo journey and Cheap Trick
what makes heavy metals so confusing
isn't that it's a bad movie it's that
the film is a series of mostly unrelated
vignettes strung together into a
disjointed anthology of sex violence and
rock and roll
good
the only thing connecting all the
different segments of heavy metal is a
vague unifying concept of the sum of all
evils being present these days the film
is more famous for being parodied by
South Park in the season 12 episode
major boobage which makes much more
sense than the movie since it's all just
a drug-induced hallucinogenic trip that
Kenny endures
Richard linklater's 2001 film Waking
Life Chronicles a man stumbling his way
through multiple unrelated realities in
a Fugue State what makes this movie so
unique is its style of Animation
rotoscoping in which animators basically
Trace every film frame of a live-action
sequence as a cartoon while rotoscoping
has become more popular in recent years
at the time this was a wholly unusual
way of making a movie Waking Life is
unabashedly an experimental film without
any kind of cohesive storyline for
audiences to latch onto it follows in
the footsteps of linklater's previous
film Slacker by Meandering from scene to
scene and character to character without
any connections between them Waking Life
also hinges on complicated and
pretentious philosophical themes which
are constantly being discussed by the
characters as the film progresses we are
the authors of ourselves co-authoring a
gigantic Dostoevsky novel starring
clowns although the film has a notable
critical Acclaim within 80 on Rotten
Tomatoes it nonetheless can be an
inscrutable and confusing film for
audiences who enjoy a comprehensible
plot
1988's Who Framed Roger Rabbit proved to
the world that combining live action
with animations can work perfectly in a
mainstream Hollywood movie on the other
hand 1992's cool world equally proved
that it can totally backfire when your
movie just isn't very good Ralph vacci's
attempt to piggyback off the success of
Robert zemeckis's more popular film
featured a young Brad Pitt as a Noir
detective for the cartoon landscape of
cool world while Cool World's animation
is certainly impressive its ability to
combine cartoon and live action elements
is not but the film's biggest failure is
that its story is borderline
incomprehensible critics at the time
noted just how hard it was to enjoy a
movie that's impossible to follow in his
1992 review for the Los Angeles Times
Peter Raynor asserted that the plot
makes almost no sense
what can I say sweetheart I can't help
you out in that department it doesn't
help that the film was consistently
compared to the much better received Who
Framed Roger Rabbit which has an easy to
follow mystery narrative there's a
reason cool world has gone down as one
of the most hated movies of all time
despite finding some success as a cult
classic
1987's The Brave Little Toaster follows
the heartwarming quest of a sentient
toaster and his Appliance friends as
they try to reunite with their lost
owner similar to Pixar's Toy Story which
would come years later the inanimate
objects of this world are all actually
alive but pretend to be dormant whenever
a human is around while the story of The
Brave Little Toaster is easy enough to
follow for audiences what really makes
the film so confusing for younger
audiences is just how intense it is
because of its nature as an independent
feature film the creators were able to
put in much darker themes than what
would have been allowed with rival
companies like Disney or Warner Brothers
The Brave Little Toaster puts its main
characters into genuine life-threatening
danger multiple times throughout the
narrative in ways that genuinely scared
its younger audience one musical number
stands out as being confusingly dark
since it depicts living cars at a
junkyard singing about their
worthlessness before being crushed to
death by a large machine in his review
for film freak Central Walter cha said
it best when he described the film as
Blade Runner for children
The Black Cauldron stands out as being a
lost Disney movie forgotten to time and
rarely referenced in discussions of the
company's greatest animated Works
nonetheless the film has gained a
significant cult following over the
years thanks to its uniquely dark
complex and intriguing World which
stands out during a particularly slow
era of Animation the Black Cauldron
features a surprisingly stacked cast of
voice performers including John Houston
John Hurt Susan Sheridan and Freddie
Jones although it's gained some
appreciation in recent years the Black
Cauldron is mostly seen as an overly
ambitious and confusing piece of Dark
Fantasy filmmaking based on the book
series The Chronicles of pradane the
film follows the Journey of a young man
named tauren who tries to stop the
devious horned King from getting a
powerful Black Cauldron that will help
him completely conquer the world
although critics applauded its animation
many felt the story itself was
uninteresting and and underdeveloped
Charles Champlin of the Los Angeles
Times succinctly described the problem
with the Black Cauldron by saying it
lacked the Simplicity and the clarity of
Great Fairy Tales
1978's watershipped down is an
adaptation of a novel by Richard Adams
which tells the story of a group of
talking rabbits in the English
Countryside the film has become known
for its deeply imaginative lore
compelling narrative and poignant
message on the necessity of preserving
the natural world what makes this
animated film confusing for many viewers
is the dichotomy between the cutesy
cartoon look of the rabbits and the
intents foreboding imagery of death and
destruction of their environment the
field
[Music]
but Adams created an intricate world
with its own mythology for his novel in
a 2014 Reddit AMA he said he even
created an entire rabbit language for
the story called Lapine for many
watching Watership Down this all may be
a bit overwhelming after all it's a
movie that looks like it would be about
cute little rabbits being cute together
David Robinson of the times noted in his
piece down the rabbit hole and into
Disneyland that people watching without
knowledge of the book beforehand May
struggle to keep up adding that they
might have a little difficulty with the
special lore and language of Richard
Adams rabbit civilization